. CALL THIS HEARING
OF THE IRAN CALL THE COMMITTEE
TO ORDER WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM YET WE JUST HAD CENTER
STERN HE- MYSTERIOUSLY
DISAPPEARED BUT THERE'S A STOCK
OKAY ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
BRING BACK. SO LET'S START WITH
AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND- LET OUR
FRIEND. FROM CHINO. FEMALE I
KNOW. SHE KNOWS WE KNOW.
RECEIVE IT BEFORE YOU KNOW IT
SAYS DOLLARS A QUORUM I'VE
TALKED TO PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ALLEN HERE ALLEN HERE
BATES DOLLY. ALI HERE HELLO
HELLO HERE SKINNER STERN BY
CASKEY AKOWSKI HERE. STERN HERE
AS WELL. FOR THE RESULT ALL
RIGHT EXCITING SO SENATOR YES
YOU MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS SB TWO TEN
ESTABLISHES SMOG CHECK
REQUIREMENTS FOR MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS AMENDMENTS
TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION AMONG
OTHERS SPECIFICALLY AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN TO REMOVE
DUPLICATIVE TESTING REGULATIONS
CAP THE PROGRAM FEE AT THIRTY
DOLLARS ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS TOOLS FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
AND OVERSIGHT PROVIDE
REASONABLE PATHWAYS FOR
INDUSTRY COMPLIANCE WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH CTA THE AG
COMMUNITY AND AIR QUALITY
ADVOCATES TO HELP ENSURE
COMPLIANCE. WHILE IMPROVING THE
STATE'S AIR QUALITY OVER THE
NEXT DECADE SB TWO TEN WILL
ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF HARMFUL
PARTICULATE MATTER EQUIVALENT
TO TAKING THREE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND TRUCKS
OFF THE ROAD MEMBERS WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS BILL WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON IT FOR THREE
YEARS AND WE HOPE THAT IT GETS
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY BACK TO
THE FLOOR IN THE SENATE AND
THEN HEADED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I HAVE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. YES SIR MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BILL MCGOVERN THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR I'M
GLAD TO SEE YOU UNDER BETTER
CIRCUMSTANCES TODAY THAN
YESTERDAY I THINK A MUCH BETTER
BUILDING YESTERDAY HE WAS THE
CHAIRMAN. OF THE CAN'T DISAGREE
AT AND WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF SB
TO TEND THIS BILL IS THE
BIGGEST CHANCE THAT YOU HAVE
THIS YEAR TO CLEAN UP THE AIR
POLLUTION THAT IS LITERALLY
CHOKING SO MANY CALIFORNIANS WE
KNOW WE HAVE A SMOG CHECK
PROGRAM FOR CARS. BUT FOR HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS THERE ACTUALLY IS
NO INSPECTION PROGRAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE EMISSION CONTROLS
ARE WORKING PROPERLY AND WE'RE
GETTING THE EMISSION LEVELS
THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO. AND IN
FACT STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
ACTUAL EMISSIONS ON THE ROAD
CAN BE UP TO TEN TIMES GREATER
THAN THE MISSIONS THAT ARE
CERTIFIED SO. THIS IS IMPORTANT
BILL WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR YES ALEXANDER CAL
STARTS POLICY DIRECTOR JUST FOR
A REFRESHER CAL START IS A
MEMBER BASED NONPROFIT AND OUR
MEMBERS INCLUDE FREIGHT
OPERATORS FLEET OPERATORS TRUCK
OEMS AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS
SO FIRST I WANT TO NOTE I JUST
HOW IMPORTANT WE THINK THIS
BILL IS AND THAT THE CURRENT
LACK OF SMOG CHECKS REALLY
RECALL EQUATES TO AN UNFAIR TAX
ON THOSE RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
AND AN UNFAIR TAX IN OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS LONGS. AND
THE REASON AMENDMENTS TO TWO
TEN WE THINK ARE VERY
COMMONSENSE POLICIES THAT ALSO
INSURANCE PROGRAM AFFORDABILITY
AND FAIRNESS I'M AND IT WILL
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD ACROSS
TRUCK OPERATORS BY INSURING
THAT EVERYONE'S HELD TO THE
SAME STANDARDS WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERSHIP AND
YOU KNOW REALLY PROVIDING A
WORKABLE APPROACH TO TAMPING
DOWN ON GROSS POLLUTERS WHILE
AVOIDING UNNECESSARY RED TAPE.
AND THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THIS BILL BE PASSED
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ARE YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON WILL BEAR WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA ALSO PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS LEGISLATION WE
ORDER SUPPORT AND WE WANT TO
REPRESENT THE SUPPORT OF TWENTY
OTHER HEALTH ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S HEAR FROM FOLKS ON ONCE
YOU CAN SUPPORT. YOUR MEMBER
THRUST BUT THE ON CAMPUS SAMBAR
DIAS CATFISH AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PLUGINS ALWAYS HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. MONNING MISTER CHAIR
JUST MULLIN FO SERIES WHICH IS
A COALITION OF BUSINESS GROUPS
THAT MANY OF NAMES YOU KNOW
COMMON DAY NAMES. IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND ALSO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS. THERE ARE
MEMBERS ROBERT HARRIS ON BEHALF
VERY THE LA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN
RODRIGUEZ WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LAUREN COMMON BE ALPHA
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT. HORRIBLE SUMMER HAVE A
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. OKAY AS FOLKS WHO WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
OPPOSITION. MOVE ONE WE GIVE
THEM HELLO TO SPACE. INSTEAD
THEY'RE OUT HAD TO GO TO THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING PUBLIC
POWER PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE NO OBJECTIONS TO THE
CREATION OF A NEW SMOG CHECK
PROGRAM AND CREATE THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THE BILL BY
THE AUTHORED HER SPONSORS OUR
CONCERN IS JUST MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S AS COST EFFECTIVE AND
FEASIBLE AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE
ONE REMAINING CONCERNED. AND
THAT'S IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT
CAN BE DONE TO ENCOURAGE AIR BE
TO ALLOW ONSITE MOBILE TESTING
AND THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO US
WE DON'T HAVE TO DRIVE OUR
TRUCKS ANDCREATE MORE MISSIONS
TO GO TO SOME CENTRALIZED
TESTING PLACE IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT CAN BE DONE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO AIR BEYOND
THAT THAT WOULD BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THE S. OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
STILL POSE FOR THE SAME REASONS
THAT LIKE. BY MY COLLEAGUE AT
CMU A AND REGISTRY AFTER THE
SHOW MATH OF THE FARM BUREAU
FOR THE SAME REASON. THANK YOU
ANTHONY TENHO CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS SO SHUZHEN.
ECHOING THE CONCERNS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STIMULI. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
EVERYBODY FOR. YOUR TESTIMONY
LET'S NOW OPEN IT TO QUESTIONS
ARE ARE WONDERFUL CENTER FROM
FREMONT. ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
STAFF REPORTED TALK ABOUT
ASSEMBLY MM INSTEAD ADDED
EXEMPTIONS FOR TWO. MORE SPUR
SPECIFIED CATEGORIES VEHICLES
WHAT WERE THOSE SPECIFIED
CATEGORIES I DON'T KNOW. I
DON'T HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF ME
IN WAS IT AND WHAT WAS THE-
TOTAL WORLD WHAT WAS THE
UNIVERSE OF VEHICLES. OUR
SERVER CASKEY THERE WERE NO
MORE THE EXEMPTIONS ARE ONLY
FOR MILITARY VEHICLES AND
EMERGENCY VEHICLES.
AGRICULTURAL VEHICLES WERE
GIVEN AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY DAYS
TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE THEY'RE
NOT EXEMPT BUT THEY THEY HAVE
THIRTY DAYS THAT THE REST OF
THE WORLD DOES NOT HAVE. OKAY
SO THE EXEMPTIONS ARE STILL
JUST WITH MILITARY AND
EMERGENCY. OKAY THANK YOU THE
QUESTIONS. SENATE DOLLY. WELL I
NOR START. SO I AM I'M IN THIS
BUSINESS AND I GAVE I THINK A
LOT INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO BE IN THIS
BUSINESS. ON THE FLOOR UNDER AB
FIVE. FIRST OFF CTA IS MORE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BECAUSE-
THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
THEY HAVE IN THEIR- ASSOCIATION
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE FLEET
TRUCKS WHICH WOULD LEAST TRUCKS
AND- SO THE- THE TECHNOLOGIES.
AND THE NEWNESS OF THE TRUCKS.
ISN'T AS A BIGGER PROBLEM FOR
THEM AS IT IS FOR SOMEBODY LIKE
MYSELF WHO. HAS NEVER BEEN ABLE
TO AFFORD TO BUY A BRAND NEW
TRUCK. AND SO. IN THIS
REGULATION OF IF THE CHECK
ENGINE LIGHTS ON SO THERE ARE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF SENSORS
ON THESE TRUCKS. AND JUST TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU THE THEN THE
TRUCK THAT I HAVE THAT IS. CARB
COMPLIANT THAT HAS ALL THE.
THINGS I'M SUPPOSED TO HAVE ON
IT FOR IS IN THE SHOP ALL THE
TIME BECAUSE OF. A SENSOR GOES
OUT OR OR AND IT'S NOT DUE TO
THE AIR QUALITY PART OF IT
COULD BE. QUITE FRANKLY JUSTICE
CENTER WENT BAD AND- TRIPS
CODES LILY HUNDRDS OF CODES
GET TRIPPED ON THESE TRUCKS AND
SO YOU'RE GIVEN AUTHORITY TO.
AT THAT CHECK ENGINE LIGHT IS
ON. DEAR SAYING THAT TRUCKS
GOING TO BE RED TAG OR HAS TO
BE TAKEN SHOP IT'S A HUNDRED
AND- ABOUT A HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE HUNDRED NINETY DOLLARS AND
A HUNDRED MILE TRIP TO THE SHOP
BECAUSE I'D THEY DON'T ALLOW US
TO HAVE THE COMPUTER TO HOOK IN
WHICH IS REALLY THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS. TO HAVE ONE IF YOU DO
TERM THE REPAIR GUYS HAVE BUT
AS FOR ME TO HUNDRED AND TEN
MILES TO THE PETERBILT
DEALERSHIP THAT MY TRUCK
PLUGGED IN. AND A TWO HUNDRED
DOLLAR BILL. AND THEN
WHATEVER'S CAN BE THE CENSOR
SOMETIMES IT'S- COULDN'T IT CAN
BE. THE DRIVER AIR MADE A
SENSOR TRIP AND THEN THEY JUST
RESET IT. BUT THEY STILL CHARGE
YOU SO I THINK THAT PART OF THE
BILL IS A VERY BIG PROBLEM FOR.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE A LONG WAY
FROM WHERE THE TRUCKS GET
SERVICED NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO. IT CAN HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEIR QUALITY SYSTEM THAT
CAUSES THE TRIBUNAL WHICH THE
TRUCK IS RIGHT. RUNNING
PROPERLY. SO THE OFFICER THAT
IS GONNA BE. THE ISSUE THE
COMMERCIAL GUYS ANOTHER THING
I. MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE
DAY IS THAT THESE THESE TRUCKS
ARE EXPECTED EVERY NINETY DAYS.
EVERY NINETY DAYS YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A C. H. P. STICKER IN YOUR
WINDOW THAT. SHOWS TO THEM THAT
YOU'VE BEEN INSPECTED. THAT'S
THAT'S THE BEST PART OF IT. SO.
YOUR REQUIRE IN IT IF IT AND
THAT'S TYPICALLY. IF WE GO TO
IT IF WE GO INTO THE THEY'VE
THEY'VE TRIPPED LOOK AT THE CO
ANYWAY THE POINT OF IT IS THE
STRUCTURE VERY MUCH INSPECTED.
NOT ONLY BY THE DRIVER EVERY
DAY IT'S REQUIRED THAT YOU DO
IT. A PRE TRIP INSPECTION. AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO HAVE A NINETY
DAY INSPECTION BY A COMMERCIAL
OFFICER OR GO THROUGH A SCALE
WHERE THEY CAN CERTIFY THAT.
NUMBER TWO. WHEN THERE'S
SEVERAL THINGS THIS BILL WE'RE
CHARGING US MORE MONEY YOU'RE
GIVING MORE POWER TO THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. I JUST THINK
THIS IS. GONNA BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE SMALL SMALLER GUYS. LIKE
MYSELF OF EVEN MORE HARDSHIP
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S REALLY
IN A THE MANUFACTURERS HAVE
HAVE HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
MEETING THE TEAR FOR.
COMPLIANCE IS AND IT IN THESE
ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED SYSTEMS
AND THEY DON'T WORKED OUT WELL.
DIAZ WE THEY WENT FROM. OF
MOTHER SYSTEM TO WHAT WE CALL A
DEAF SYSTEM WHICH IS. IS
ACTUALLY PUTTING YOUR RIA. INTO
THE SYSTEM TO HELP BURN AT A
HIGHER RATE. WHICH WERE NOT
EVEN IT EATS UP THE EXHAUST
PIPES BY THE WAY SO I'M NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THAT'S
GONNA DO THE ENVIRONMENT BUT-
BUT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AIR
AND MAYBE NOT. THE OTHER PARTS
OF THAT THAT BECAUSE WE FORCED
MANUFACTURERS TO MEET MEET A
STANDARD. SO FIRST SEVERAL
THOSE REASONS IS MONICA WILL
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND I THINK
IT CAN BE VERY HARD TO.
REGULATE FOR ONE IS GONNA BE A
HARDSHIP ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING ON TOP
OF ALL THE OTHER REGULATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN PILED ON AS AN
DRIVE THE COST OF FREIGHT UP.
IN CALIFORNIA. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS OF THE OPPOSING THE
BILL. YES ENERGY IS IT POSSIBLE
HE DIVERSE YES ABSOLUTELY SO
ONE ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS WE
TOOK AS YOU HEARD THIS WAS IN
ORDER WHICH COMMITTEE BUT WE
YOU KNOW YOUHAVE SEVENTY FIVE
DAYS FOR FIX THE TICKET. THE H.
Q. EMPTY HAS COMMITTED TO US
THAT THEY WILL DO ON SITE
TESTING THAT THEY WANT TO DO ON
SITE TESTING BECAUSE WE DO
UNDERSTAND FOR SOMEONE LIKE
YOURSELF DRIVING HUNDRED AND
TEN MILES TO SET TEST CENTER IS
THAT FEASIBLE AND IN THAT ISN'T
THE GOAL OF THE OF THE BILL AT
ALL. YOU KNOW I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND WE'VE WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING WE CAN TO TRY
TO MAKE IT FOR THE SMALL GUY OF
A WAS IS EASY AS POSSIBLE BUT
AS FEASIBLE AS POSSIBLE AND I
THINK IN PART OF IT WE MAY JUST
HAVE TO AGREE TO DISAGREE BUT I
DO KNOW THAT. THEY CAN BE IS
TRYING TO DO ON SITE TESTING
BECAUSE THEY'VE HEARD AS WE'VE
SAID THAT THAT'S A PROBLEM WE
DID CHANGE IT FROM FORTY FIVE
DAY FIX THE TICKET TO A SEVENTY
FIVE DAY FIX THAT TICKET
BECAUSE WHAT WE HEARD FROM OUR
FARMERS AND GROWERS WAS THAT.
THEY DIDN'T THINK THAT DURING
THE SEASON WHEN THE HARVESTING
THAT FORTY FIVE DAYS WAS
REASONABLE I THOUGHT IT WAS
REASONABLE BUT WE. WE HEARD
THOSE CONCERNS SO WE CHANGED IT
TO SEVENTY FIVE DAYS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN YESTERDAY I JUST AMEND
MY ANSWERS CENTER WACO SKI
BECAUSE I DID LEAVE OUT ONE
THERE IS A LIMITED FOUR YEAR
EXEMPTION. FOR NEW VEHICLES
MEETING THE- OPTIONAL WILL
KNOCK STANDARD SET BY A R. B.
THE OTHER. NEW CAR THAT THAT'S
RIGHT THAT THE CLEANEST TRUCKS
WOULD GET FOR YEARS WE LOOK AT
THE MOMENT CENTER YES I WILL
OKAY. OKAY OTHER QUESTIONS YES
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE ONE IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
PREVIOUSLY HIGHLIGHTED WHICH I
SHOULD HAVE POTENTIALLY
HIGHLIGHTED IN MY TESTIMONY WAS
THAT THIS BILL APPLIES TO OUT
OF STATE VEHICLES AND SO THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. THEY WILL
HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE
AND WE HOPE THAT THAT ACTUALLY
INCREASES COMPETITIVENESS FOR
CALIFORNIA TRUCKERS BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT MOST OF THEM ARE
DOING THEIR VERY BEST TO
MAINTAIN THEIR VEHICLES WHERE
IS. A LOT OF THE GROSS
POLLUTERS ARE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER. SO WITH THE IMPACT ON
THE IN STATE. YEAH SEVEN FIVE
OUT. IN STATE SO WHAT WHERE
YOU'RE SITTING AT WITH THE WELL
I WANTED SO I READ I READ IT
EVERYTHING THAT MY CACUS GAVE
ME ON THIS BILL. AND SO. I READ
IN YOUR THAT IS THIS BILL'S
GOING TO ACTUALLY. WE'RE GOING
TO THAT IS A MAN'S. SO WE HAVE
INTERSTATE COMMERCE LAWS FOR
ONE THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS
BILL FACTS THAT MAYBE AN
ATTORNEY CAN HELP ME OUT WITH
THAT EARLY DOESN'T WE DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM I KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT I THINK THE CURRENT LAW
WAS FOR ALLOWED TO REGULATE. BM
FOLKS ON OUR ROAD HERE. IN THE
STATE YEAH RIGHT BUT THESE
PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE SO THEY'RE- IT'S LIKE.
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL BE
TREATED THE SAME AS THE ESTATE
TRUCK SO THERE'S NO
DISCRIMINATION AND SO THAT
PASSED. THERE WAS A LOT I THINK
WE'RE OPERATE. I'M TRYING TO
KEEP UP WITH A THERE'S A LOT
LAWS IN THIS. CATEGORY AND I
DON'T TRACK OUT OF STATE. SO
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH OUT OF
STATE AND INS INTERSTATE. LAWS
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE WAS I
THINK UNDER THE LAW WE HAVE NOW
IS SEVENTY FIVE YOU COULD COME
IN FOR SEVENTY FIVE HOURS. THE
WAS THE RULE. YOU EITHER COME
FROM OUT OF STATE YOU CAN BE IN
IN OUR STATE PERCENT OF OUR
LEGAL CAR CROSSES STATES EVERY
FIVE HOURS AND BACK IN. AND SO
IT REALLY DIDN'T HELP US. KEEP
OUT THE TRUCKS FROM OTHER
STATES. SO CORRECT WASN'T A
VERY COOL SO NOW IN ORDER TO
HAVE AN OPERATOR'S PERMIT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU
MUST PASS A SMOG CHECK. I
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE NO
OKAY MERGED CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION I DID JUST
WANT TO. REGISTER OUR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS TO
DEAL WITH MOBILE TESTING. DON'T
GO FAR ENOUGH WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD. PROVIDE MOBILE
TESTING OPTIONS THAT ARE TRULY.
ECONOMICALLY AND
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE FOR
THE LOW USE TRUCKS AND THE
SPECIAL EQUIPMENT AND WE- WE
HOPE WE HAVE HOPE THAT
AMENDMENT WOULD BEEN TAKEN TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS AS THEY
WERE NOT MORE SO. AND AS I
STATED BEFORE THE A. R. B. THAT
IS THEIR PLAN AND THAT IS PART
OF THE REGULATORY PROCESS. OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND NOT JUST FOR MY-
I WAS. IF YOU NEED TO SORRY I'M
SORRY. THAT MEANS OF COURSE.
YOU MAY HAVE ON. THANK YOU TIME
YEAR CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT BRING INTO A ALSO IN A
MENTION THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. HI JESSICA VOTE
IF WE WANNA. RESERVOIR IS
EITHER BEING LATE AND CHAIR I'M
NOT ROMAN CATHOLIC TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE CREEK WE
ARE NOT IN SUPPORT OF BILL WE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THE MEASURE I WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
AMENDMENTS. ESPECIALLY
REVOLVING AROUND THE FEE WE DO
SHARE A LOT OF CONCERN TO
SENATOR DOLLY MENTION ON THE
BILL HOWEVER AB. THERE ARE WE
DO BELIEVE A LOT OF THAT'S
GONNA BE ADDRESSED THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS. THINK OF
THE AT THE- COAST JACKET IN THE
ROOM TODAY. HELLO SIR BEAR WITH
THE LATE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT APOLOGIES FOR BEING
LATE. THAT ON BEING LATE AND
CHECK READY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. ALSO DITTO AS FOR
OTHER THAN THEM BEHALF OF THIS
A TRAILER QUALITY COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY ALL
RIGHT. ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
SPOTS CONCERNS AND I WILL
REMIND EVERYONE THAT I'M THE
BILL THIS IS JUST BACK FROM
CONCURRENT AND IF YOU MAKE A
COUPLE CHANGES BUT THEY'RE
PRESUMPTIVELY SOMEONE WHAT WAS.
FIRST PUSH THROUGH SO. I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. FOR THE
BILL IT'S BEEN MOVED BY. CINEMA
CASKEY SECURE PLEASE CALL. ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB TWO TEN AS A
SENATOR LEYVA THE MOTION IS
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN ALLEN AYE ALLEN
AYE BATES. BATES NO DALI. DALI
NO HILL HILL AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE STERN IN A WAY CAL
SKI THE CASKET I. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
OKAY SETS FIVE A TO VOTE AND
THAT'S I WAS HE PASSES THANK
YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN AND ALL THE
MEMBERS AND LET'S ADJOURN THIS
HEARING OF THE- EQ COMMITTEE